gym membership whole30 finally joining
that dating app
it's time for new year's resolutions new
year
new me right wrong
but everyone i know is doing a new
year's resolution so i should too right
no did you read the title of this video
absolutely not
eighty percent of people who make a new
year's resolution will abandon it by the
second week of february
and certain resolutions are even harder
to keep like
fitness or losing weight a social
network for athletes
looked at user fitness records over the
month of january
they found that u.s users were likely to
bail on their fitness resolutions
by january 12th according to forbes
the number of new year's resolutions
that are actually achieved
eight percent those numbers
don't look good why do we suck at
resolutions
well to start with they're often vague
and hard to measure
consider the popular resolutions get in
shape
what shape hourglass square octagon
travel more okay where exactly how long
you know there's a pandemic going on
don't you have more sex
okay with whom yourself let's be
realistic
no one can follow through with stuff's
that broad if you want to hold yourself
accountable
you have to be more specific another
reason resolutions fail
because we don't just need to change our
behavior we need to alter our
consciousness
[Music]
[Applause]
but seriously behavior is hard to change
when we haven't
mentally prepared to do so humans hate
change because we don't like to abandon
what's comfortable
to successfully change you need to know
why you're changing
you want to quit smoking think about why
you smoke
is it stress there might be something
else you need to address
first and if you're pursuing a new
year's resolution because of some sort
of social pressure
you might not really believe you deserve
to achieve your goal
or are you afraid that by actually
succeeding you might leave
others behind what will your friends
think you try hard
finally resolutions don't succeed
because if we don't see instantaneous
results
we already feel like we failed and we
give up it's hard to commit to big
change and if you have some
hyper-specific idea of your desired
outcome
say you want to get in shape and that
shape's an octagon
if you don't achieve that a deal you
might lose sight of the real ways you
benefited
all right so is there any hope is there
any way that my resolution can be
in that eight percent that succeed maybe
if you make a specific resolution say
eat an extra helping of vegetables
every day for two months and you have to
know why you're doing it you have to
really believe that extra helping of
vegetables
is going to change your life you have to
commit to those vegetables
don't ghost those vegetables marry
those vegetables
but most importantly don't make a
resolution just because everyone else is
doing it
that's going to be a waste of money and
time
what's the root cause of your
unhappiness is it the stress
is it self-esteem address the real
issues and leave the fitness discounts
to the suckers
[Music]
[Music]
you